ننتقل الى موضوع اخر حيث وارتفع عدد ضحايا
العاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب الولايات
المتحده منذ يوم الجمعه الماضي الى نحو 50
قتيلا وذلك بعد اعلان ولايه نيويورك
ارتفاع عدد ضحايا في مدينه بافلو بالولايه
الى 25 قتيلا وقالت السلطات نيويورك ان
بعض الضحايا وجدوا متجمدين من البرد في
سيارتهم ومنازلهم في حين لقي اخرون
اصابتهم بازمه القلبيه خلال ازالتهم
الثلوج من اذان منازلهم وحول سيارتهم ادت
العاصفه الى الغاء 15 الف رحله جويه خلال
الايام الاخيره وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي
عن اكثر من مليون شخص واغلاق عدد كبير من
الطرق
رئيس
الجنسيه
من رفع حظر قياده السيارات في بعض المناطق
لكنه مستمر في مدينه التي لا تزال معظم
طرقها مغلقه خصوصا الشوارع الثانويه
والجانبيه ويرجعوا ذلك الى ان جهودنا تركز
في المقام الاول على فتح الطرق حول
المستشفيات ودوري رعايه المسنين
وهناك سيارات في كل مكان